[Musique]
drapeaux péruviens et concerts de klaxon
dell annonce de la démission du
président manuel mérino ils sont
plusieurs centaines à fêter la nouvelle
dans les rues de lima la capitale
[Musique]
il n'a pas démissionné le peuple l'a mis
dehors merino n'a jamais été président
il ne m'a jamais représenté que puis je
dire de plus maintenant le congrès doit
partir il faut une nouvelle constitution
trop tard c'est trop tard il a attendu
que nous ayons des morts pour
démissionner sous la pression et
démissionner un mensonge nous l'avons
sorti il n'a pas démissionné
il a attendu que des gens meurent ce
samedi ils étaient des milliers à
manifester contre le nouveau
gouvernement du président intérimaire
manuel mérino nommé quatre jours
auparavant suite à la destitution de
l'ancien président péruvien martin
vizcarra pour incapacité moral sur fond
d'accusations de pots-de-vin présumés
qu'il aurait reçus en tant que
gouverneur en 2014
une manifestation qui avait dégénéré en
affrontements violents avec la police
faisant au moins deux morts parmi les
manifestants et une centaine de blessés
le lendemain à l'issue d'une réunion
extraordinaire tenue par les députés il
annonce finalement sa démission
je présente ma démission irrévocable de
la fonction de président de la
république et j'appelle à la paix et à
l'unité de tous les péruviens le
parlement péruvien doit désormais nommer
un nouveau président parmi ses membres
une tâche qui s'annonce difficile
cette nuit les parlementaires ont tenté
en vain d'introniser une élue de gauche
rocio silva santisteban cet ancien
activiste des droits de l'homme n'a
obtenu que 42 votes sur les 60 requis
avec 52 votes contre et 25 abstentions
[Musique]